and the girls started watching movies
that I have been in they call them mom
movies which is really sweet I will say
it's weird for me still though when I
flip through and I see Drew I'm like
wait a second I know you
that's weird what's it like when you see
yourself on movies like unexpectedly I'm
like oh
and then I just keep going keep going oh
stop and pause for a minute but then I
think I'm so afraid to be caught
watching my own films and I just you
know eventually quickly move on you know
I was just on a plane not that long ago
and all your movies were on and I was
watching One on a plane and I thought oh
this is weird if people seem like Ross
don't you work with her
so now I'm thinking that if it's you
watching it that's even weirder if they
catch you that by the way a film that I
was on I think it was like a Wedding
Singer or something was on a plane and
it was on the screen that I had and I
quickly turned it because I was like can
you imagine if anybody walked by